This is a great topic that came up yesterday
during a livestream and it touches on politics,
it touches on finance, it touches on economics.
So let's let's dove right into it.
Why did the stock market go way up last Thursday
when the news was breaking, 6.6 million more
people have lost their jobs and have filed
for unemployment benefits because one would
imagine that bad economic news would cause
the stock market to go down, not up precipitously.
But the opposite happened, indeed, last Thursday
when the terrible unemployment news broke.
Stocks went absolutely skyrocketing for the
day.
And it has confused a lot of different people.
And it's a great opportunity to talk through
many of the different elements that are factors
here.
So there's a few different things going on.
First of all, if you want, you can just write
all of this off as mere speculation by market
insiders.
Right.
You can argue the stock market doesn't even
really have any connection to the news of
what's going on within the economy.
It's just traders speculating and pushing
stocks up and pushing stocks down, sometimes
taking long positions, sometimes taking short
positions when it benefits them.
And there's just no meaning whatsoever in
market moves related to what's happening in
the economy.
Now, of course, there's an element of truth
to that.
There's no doubt that hedge funds, derivative
instruments, a lot of these nonproductive
financial mechanisms can benefit from and
even move markets or exacerbate market moves
without being directly tied to some factual
change on Main Street for the average person.
But it's only a piece of it.
It's not really a comprehensive analysis and
it lacks some understanding of some pretty
basic economic concepts.
Now, before I jump into this in more detail,
there's two things that I should mention.
Number one, any effort to explain why stocks
went up or down on a particular day is a fool's
errand in the sense that there is no real
way to definitively say, here's why the market
was up or here.
Here's why the market was down on any particular
day.
We're doing this more as a thought experiment.
Number two, I understand that lots of the
ideas that I'm going to use today are partially
debunked in the sense that standard economic
theory, a rational actor, efficient market
economics has been partially debunked and
that is undeniable.
But it still is an OK fret framework as an
entry point to start thinking about some of
these things.
So all of those disclaimers out of the way,
let's now play the game.
So the first thing to understand is that the
stock market is supposed to already reflect
future news that we can expect.
This is a classic economics term called efficient
markets hypothesis.
And put very simply, what what efficient markets
hypothesis asserts is that asset prices, the
price of the Dow, the NASDAQ, the S&P 500,
it reflects all available information.
Now, sometimes information is available, but
it's about a future event that hasn't happened
yet.
Efficient markets hypothesis argues information
about future events is also priced into the
stock market.
Now, of course, efficient market hypothesis
is one of those things they teach us early
in economics, academia and to some degree
it is complete and total B.S.
It's only sort of true if the market's really
priced in all future information.
There wouldn't be any way to make money in
the market and you know, eventually brought
to to absurdity.
Eventually the sun will expand and engulf
the earth and everybody on the planet will
die unless we move to some other planet.
If that was priced in, stock markets would
be at zero because we already know that that's
eventually going to happen.
So, again, it's just an idea.
It's a framework.
It doesn't work 100 percent.
But as applied to the unemployment numbers
from last week, even though the 6.6 million
additional people filing for unemployment
was announced on Thursday, it was expected
for more than a week ahead of time.
And there were predictions about the number
of millions of people that would be filing
for unemployment.
So arguably, it was already priced into the
market now.
That could explain why stocks didn't crash
on the announcement of unemployment numbers
last Thursday.
But it doesn't really explain why stocks actually
went up drastically on that news.
That doesn't seem to make sense.
Well, that gets us to layer 2 of the analysis,
which is markets don't like uncertainty, even
though there was the expectation of millions
of people losing their jobs last week.
Once it was announced, the uncertainty was
removed.
So if you expect 6.6 million people to lose
their jobs.
And then it's confirmed that 6.6 million people
lose their jobs.
You remove the uncertainty, 6.6 million plus
the uncertainty of will it be more or will
it be less is worse arguably than just knowing
it's 6.6 million people who lost their jobs.
So that could make stocks go up.
Lastly, when you file for unemployment benefits,
you start to get money.
So from a market perspective, what is going
to happen to the companies on the stock market
when you learn almost 7 million people are
going to start getting money.
They're going to start getting unemployment
benefits coming in, which they will spend
with a lot of these companies that trade on
the stock market.
That could cause stocks to go up on the news
of 6.6 million new unemployment claims.
And then lastly, when you learn that nearly
7 million more people lost their jobs, meaning
around 17 million people have lost jobs in
just three weeks.
That's a signal that this is bad enough that
the government might do more stimulus.
And again, stimulus injects money, much of
which goes to the companies that are traded
on various stock exchanges.
So thinking about it this way, we at least
have a plausible explanation for why terrible
unemployment news correlates with the stock
market going up.
Lastly, remember, this is more proof that
the stock market going up doesn't mean that
Main Street or the average worker individually
is doing well.
Six trillion in stimulus could be great in
the aggregate for the market.
But if the individual person is getting a
twelve hundred dollar check seven weeks after
they've been sitting at home or whatever,
the case may be a bit maybe more like five
weeks in some cases.
You can very quickly see how aggregate market
stimulus can be very good for the stock market,
but not that good for the individual person
who has way more than twelve hundred dollars
in bills overdue and is just now getting their
twelve hundred dollar check.
Let me know if this type of segment is useful
or interesting.
And you know, I try to explain.
This is the economic concept.
It's partially B.S., right?
I mean, a lot of standard economics is partially
B.S., but it can still serve to be useful
in thinking about a particular news event
in this case, bad unemployment news combined
with the stock market going up.